bonjour david alors la mobilisation est
elle au rendez vous aurez plusieurs
milliers de personnes se sont réunies à
place de l'opéra le cortège s'est élancé
il y à quelques minutes pour se rendre
de la place de la république et vous
l'entendez derrière moi l'ambiance est
plutôt festive et musicale l'objectif
est dé dénoncé une trahison à
démocratique et bagel macouin est accusé
par les associations environnementales
à l'initiative de ce rassemblement de ne
pas avoir à respecter son engagement
vis-à-vis un tueur un climat et du
contrat démocratique passé avec la
convention un citoyenne plusieurs élus
politiques
elles sont également un présentons ici à
busan du cortège organisateurs et élus
politiques marchent main dans la main
afin de dénoncer ce contrat est passé à
laquelle le président français qui n'est
pas à la hauteur de l'urgence climatique
vous propose à de les écouter
c'est important parce que là c'est un
moment absolument unique où la seule loi
en fait climat du gouvernement du
quinquennat va passer à l'assemblée
nationale lundi 29 donc demain donc là
c'est l'occasion en fait de montrer de
faire masse et de notre gouvernement
qu'on n'est pas du tout content de cette
loi qu'on n'est pas du tout content que
les mesures qui ont été prises elles se
sont impliqués avec beaucoup beaucoup
trop de suite contrairement à ce que
macro avait dit les mesures sont loin
loin loin d'être ambitieuse et même pas
un dixième des mesures qu'ils le sont
aujourd'hui
le président m'a fonds avait avait donné
à 150 citoyens les clés pour résoudre un
problème comment nous faisons la
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2050 et
leur avait dit sans filtre je donnerais
l'ensemble de vos propositions soient
directement au parlement soit
directement aux citoyens par était un
homme est en réalité il a il a mis
beaucoup de filtre et à l'arrivée cette
loi climat qui nous est proposé elle est
complètement dénaturé et elle ne
répondra pas à l'urgence climatique et
sociale qui est qui est devant nous
poser donc il seul un mouvement
populaire peut obliger contraint de
l'exécutif en revenir dessus et à
proposer une vraie loi climat qui
répondent aux enjeux du 21e siècle la
loi climat qui sera examiné à partir de
demain à l'assemblée nationale ce
rassemblement a pour but de mettre la
pression sur les députés parlementaires
afin qu'ils proposent autre chose
une loi la hauteur des espérances et de
la convention climatique
les 150 membres de la convention
climatique espère qu'avec cette
mobilisation d'ampleur ici à à paris
j'ai un député vous à réagir dès demain
et avec avec ce vote en a qui sera
débattue dès demain à l'assemblée
nationale
merci à david pour toutes ces précisions